First, let's review why you need data preparation. Unlike when you're working in games where you build assets one at a time,
when your goal is construction or manufacturing, it often means that your project or design is most likely already fully assembled and arranged in a certain way.
In that respect, you may have hundreds or thousands of objects already set up that you need to import into Unreal in a meaningful way,
preserving hierarchies and pivot points. This is where Datasmith excels.
Your existing pipeline may include DCC software that require a dedicated plugin to export to Datasmith, which you can download from the Unreal Engine website.
If you are using CAD applications like Solidworks or KTIA to name a couple, then these files will be read natively by Datasmith and you do not need to convert them.
Let's look at importing a Datasmith file into Unreal Engine to get a feel for that procedure, and then we'll talk about how the information is processed.
By this time, you should have downloaded and extracted the project files that have been provided to you.
Find the project named VisualDataPrep.vueProject and launch it.
It opens in Unreal Engine and the Content Browser has a set of subfolders in it.
We'll take a quick look at basic Datasmith ingestion and then proceed to learn about automation.
Start a new level.
Create a folder in the Content Browser named Tutorial, which we'll use as a working folder.
To import a Datasmith file, use the Add to Project button on the main toolbar and the Import Datasmith File option.
Keep in mind the Datasmith menu section may or may not be available by default based on the template you chose to start the project.
If the option doesn't appear, then you need to enable one or more Datasmith plugins in the Plugins dialog.
Using Datasmith File Import, browse to select the file gocard.3dm under the project's Assets-Ryno subfolder.
For a location to store the file, select the tutorial folder you just created and click OK.
Next, you are asked to select the type of information you wish to import.
This file has no lights, cameras or animations in it, so you can disable these options.
You can also adjust tessellation options in this dialog to control the conversion of nerve surfaces into triangulated geometry,
but this affects all imported parts globally. Leave these to their default settings. Later, you'll learn ways to use them on selected parts.
Click Import to bring the model in.
Reset the position of the floor to drop it a notch.
You might also consider moving the SunSky system to see better.
The information is now inside of Unreal Engine and neatly organized in folders in the Content Browser.
Note the little stars on the thumbnail, an indication that even though it was imported, the data is not saved yet.
Click the Save All button in the Content Browser to remedy that. If your level is not saved yet, you'll be asked to give it a name.
Call it My Cart and save it to the Tutorial Working folder.
The data is now in the engine and you can start adjusting it. For example, you could consider re-tessellating a few parts that look rough when seen up close.
Set the camera speed appropriately and investigate the tires, wheels and tubular chassis parts, or the steering wheel for that matter.
You'll notice they could use a little help.
You can also temporarily switch to wireframe mode to better see the problem areas.
Let's test the wheels.
Their instances are based on a single Static Mesh, as you can see here in the Content Browser.
Double-click the wheel or rim Static Mesh to open it in the Static Mesh Editor.
To view the topology, a classic trick is to enable Complex Collision mode.
To re-tessellate this part, use the Re-Tessellate action from the Asset menu.
Expand the panel and you can adjust the values to adjust the detail.
Try a Core Tolerance of 0.05, a Maximum Edge Length of 2 and leave the Normal Tolerance to 20.
These parameters are covered in more detail in the Basic Datasmith Ingestion class.
Click Tessellate to bring about the necessary changes to the Static Mesh, which now looks much more detailed.
Save the information and close the Static Mesh Editor.
The wheels now look much better, but of course, you'd need to do this for every other part of the go-kart that needs it,
like the tires, the jagged looking tubes that make the chassis, the steering wheel and so on.
Of course, if the goal was to use the same tessellation values for all meshes,
then you could have done that at import time, that process would have been global.
But if you're planning different tessellation values for different meshes or groups of meshes, then you'd need to deal with those individually in the Static Mesh Editor.
Also, you would need to consider creating LODs for the various parts, and that is also done usually one Static Mesh at a time.
And that would require another trip to the Static Mesh Editor to set LODs manually or by LOD group.
None of it is hard per se, just time consuming, especially if you have too many Static Meshes.
Finally, you may need to consider replacing incoming materials with better ones that you may have already in your PBR library.
Again, not a hard task but one that could take time.
In this case, it is easy enough to select all the chassis parts that are neatly organized in the Outliner,
and replace their materials in one sweep.
Also keep in mind that this particular example is a simple one with only a few meshes and materials to consider,
and yet you can appreciate the nature of the repetitive tasks awaiting you.
So you can extrapolate and guess how time consuming a larger project might be.
And so, let's look at how we can automate these tasks.
We'll first look at Python scripting and then move to the Visual Data Prep tool.
Click the Save All button to save the project before moving on.